welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and marvel's the falcon and the
winter soldier on disney plus appears to
be the first marvel face war story that
deals with the actual societal
implications of avengers endgame pushed
to 2021 after one division but
hopefully sometime earlier in that year
based on some new
looks we're getting from the cast closer
examinations of trailer footage
and leftover overlooked details from
avengers in-game we are starting to get
a much
clearer picture of the big twist of the
falcon the winter soldier
how this show's going to set up the mcu
future and really how it's exploring a
post in game society beyond you know
spider-man's high school
spoiler warning because i am going to
break down the huge secret that might
have been
right beneath the surface of what we've
been looking at now some of what we're
seeing has come from the cast themselves
goofing around
on set including looks at falcon's new
suit but we've also seen
externally taken set photos so an
additional warning
in case you don't want to see what's
probably going to get revealed in the
trailer in the weeks ahead anyway okay
we got a visual confirmation that
joining the cast
is emily van camp as sharon carter
returning from captain america civil war
setting up a likely callback to bucky
and sam's lurker moment
wow that might be in zest the in-game
screenwriters reveal that they intended
on including a scene showing cap and
sharon carter living together
in an unhappy relationship so i'm
wondering if this series might reference
that leftover subplot but the set photos
also confirmed an even more shocking
return
george st pierre as batroc the leaper
from the opening act of captain america
winter soldier
and he's leaping back into his purple
and gold color scheme from the comics
also appearing on set have been desmond
chiam in an unknown role
and aaron kellyman on a park bench in a
scene described by onlookers as
bad truck and chimp's character meeting
with kellyman's character who shows off
some
mystery power emitting a signal to put
nearby people in a trance and draw them
in therefore many believe that kellyman
is playing melissa gold aka
songbird who has the power to manipulate
the minds of people with
a supersonic frequency voice songbird
was formerly known as scream and mimi a
super villain who
along with zemo who is of course joining
this cast make up the villains posing as
avenger replacements
the thunderbolts but songbird is one of
the first members of that group to turn
good
flipping the rest of the team against
zemo i believe that the falcon the
winter soldier is adapting this
thunderbolt arc as a plot
with zemo who in the absence of avengers
like captain
america tony stark black widow vision
thor who's now off world
hatches a plan with thunderbolt ross to
form a new super team of a-holes
including us agent john walker as a new
cap figure
bad truck songbird cheam as maybe the
fixer
maybe even other past mcu villains like
ghost now it looks like us agent will
get his hands on cap's shield we saw
that in the trailer and some local
snoopers on the set captured video
showing him fighting with that shield
and bucky's cleaned up look shows him
with the black vibranium arm that
t'challa and sure he gave him in
infinity war
so it looks like this post-endgame
society is trying to
replace sam and bucky despite them being
the successors cap chose
likely due to authorities like ross
still enforcing the sokovia accords
something the endgame writers confirmed
was still legally binding but as we
learned in the post-credits scenes of
civil war and black panther
nations like wakanda don't exactly
subscribe to sokovia's newsletter
and i think that wakanda connection will
be
key to sam and bucky catching those
false heroes zemo
and u.s agent off guard in a really cool
way look i know there's a lot of clues
we gotta sift through
because the best visual clues are hiding
in plain sight just like someone's front
pocket wallet like the ridge
thanks to the ridge for sponsoring this
episode the ridge helps you carry what
you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack
they want you to make the most out of
what you're bringing with you the ridge
wallet is made out of military-grade
materials like titanium and carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design it is
so when jason voorhees is trying to kill
you he won't be able to kill your credit
cards this is their
aluminum silver wallet they do have
other colors including some very flashy
tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong just
like you
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee
it's also got thirty thousand five star
reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocky pockets and the optional device
charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
newrockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description okay so i believe
the wakanda
backup to the falcon winter soldier runs
a lot deeper than bucky's arm though
i must say i always found it interesting
that his arm
dusted along with him in infinity war
that it was already such a part of his
identity the same way vision's
flesh is vibranium atom infused tissue
with neurons wired to the mind stone and
what some consider to be a soul
it's as if the wakandan metal attached
to bucky bonded to his identity
made unique to his dna not a weapon he
totes around like that gun that he
dropped mid dust and it did not dust
along with him
but a vibranium extension of his
identity and on that line i believe
something very similar is going on with
the other
major wakandan weapon given to the
avengers returning in this series
cap's new shield and i say new shield
because yeah the shield we're seeing in
this new footage
is not the vibranium one forged by
howard stark back in the 40s that cap is
used for most of the infinity saga that
shield got broken by thanos and was last
seen on cap's arm in the battle of earth
flinging off his arm in that blast from
thanos destroying the quantum tunnel in
the van but rather this new shield came
with
cap from an alternate timeline and in
the falcon winter soldier notice the
notches and indentations this is the
same shield old cap gave to sam at the
end of end game it's a new shield a
shield from an alternate history and a
shield i have speculated in the past to
be
proto-adamantium the vibranium steel
alloy that caps shield is composed of in
the marvel comics
and right after i theorized that in a
past video fortnite came out with a new
capped skin that labeled that shield as
proto-adamantium but you know fortnite
isn't
really mcu canon well i guess it kinda
is thanks to korg and new master 69
and donald muster cameo in as a wizard
so who knows anyway many have noticed
the new grooves and notches on that
shield but i don't think anyone has come
up with an answer as to
why those notches are there or what role
they could play in the falcon winter
soldier like notice how that central
star
on the shield is composed of segments
diamond shaped or i guess i should say
elongated hexagonal shaped it's odd to
design a shield surface that way if you
think about it you would want a sturdy
monolithic surface to absorb the impact
but the pieces
suggest something more dynamic in the
engineering actually i gotta say the
shapes of those segments remind me a lot
of the shape of the gauntlet
shields that t'challa hooked cap up with
in infinity war
get this man shoot the way they use
vibranium and wakanda it's amorphous
it can be rock-solid or it can be fluid
and shape-shifting
so i believe this new shield was given
to cap by wakanda in an alternate
timeline and it's composed of a new form
of vibranium a new alloy that we will be
calling
proto-adamantium and it has secret
detachable parts
projectiles and properties that are only
activated when wielded by
its rightful owner a simple shield in
the hands of fakers like us
agent but something so much more in the
hands of sam wilson
that hidden functionality could be what
we see him struggling to activate in the
trailer footage but ultimately i think
this new shield can only be activated in
tandem
with another weapon gifted by wakanda
bucky's arm
metal to metal fist on shield key in
lock
awakening this shield from sleep mode to
wakandan instant kill so that sam wilson
and bucky barnes only by working
together can rally against zemo's
thunderbolts and reclaim the title
of avengers discuss these marvel
theories with me on new rockstar's
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstar
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
eavos follow me rockstars thank you for
watching and uh let's hope roadie isn't
around when bucky awakens sam's shield
by punching it
you looking for this this isn't your
moment rhody scram
[Music]
you